hello everyone and welcome to an
extremely wild game that was played in
round 6 of the 2018 Korchnoi Memorial
it's played between Russian Grandmaster
David Peruvian and the Russian
international masters available above
now a lot of you have requested me to
check out this game here are only a
couple of your suggestions saying like
it's a magnificent game probably one of
the best detecting games of modern chess
era and you might think ok this agamotto
dude has a chess channel he probably
knows every game that's going on in the
world but that actually couldn't be
further from the truth
I mean of course I tried to follow
what's going on but your suggestions do
are of great help because today was
actually the first day I saw this game I
read on Twitter that such a game was
played and they were spectacular and and
stuff but up until today I haven't seen
it and if you're wondering what's up
with the quest in the top left corner of
your screen we'll get back to that after
we check out the game so let's see this
beauty now it has the white pieces and
he opens with E 4 we have E 5 Knight to
f3 and the knight to f6 two Russian guys
playing the petrov very nice Knight
captures on e5 we have D 6 to the
classical variation Knight to f3 Knight
captures on e4 d4 d5 and Bishop to d3
this is still the classical variation
Bishop to d6 we have castles castles c4
and c6 and if you're if you're a Petrov
player or if you you know come across
against someone who plays the petrov
chances are you've been in this exact
same position quite a lot of times have
been in a disposition with the black and
white pieces in online chess and over
the board chess as well and it's very
interesting you can try a lot of things
here for example rook to e1 Bishop f5
and then go into a series of exchanges
so it's a knight c3 captures captures
Bishop captures Queen captures captures
captures and a lot of games were
actually played in this fashion but here
we have a very interesting approach by
dogged heroes Queen to b3
and this is a very rare move only a
handful of games have been played using
the queen bee three move that can be
found in the database one one notable
game that was played was in 2007 in the
European Cup where Nigel short played
Queen B 3 and he beat up and Tala Hari
Krishna with it but how the krishna went
to Bishop to g4 here but in this game
Sevilla global goes D captures on c4 so
already on move 9 we have a position
that was never before seen in in
high-level chess or in it cannot be find
found in a database so now we have a
completely original game Bishop captures
on c4 we have Knight to d7
we have rook to e1 attacking the knight
here Knight the D to f6 simply improving
the position Knight bTW to Knight
captures Bishop captures and here we
have Queen to b6 some really offers a
trade of Queens here and here we have
the critical moment of the game queen d3
offering a pawn here now is this a
poisoned pawn you can you can try and
you know check out the position for a
bit and try and figure out for yourself
is this pawn poisoned it doesn't appear
to be poison because Queen can always
find find her way out
Queen capture son b2 was played Galoob
of accepts the challenge and let's see
what happened here
rook a2 b1 was played Queen to a3
offering a trade of Queens and now Queen
to c2 so now if you look at this this
rook is controlling the B file so let's
just mark those with to read the dark
square Bishop controls a5 the Queen
controls a4 and the bishop as you can
see controls a6 so the Queen doesn't
really have any school and the point
guard c5 so the Queen doesn't really
have any squares to go to if you're able
to attack the Queen you will most likely
win the Queen here the the most
essential move in the position is b5 you
have to kick this Bishop back Bishop to
b3 and now escape with the Queen so this
is a must a must play move but Knight to
d5 was played by go Luba and here we
have rook to b3 so ok the queen is
attacked but now the Queen is no longer
guarding day for square you can play
pay for but here comes the problem
Bishop captures on d5
you have to recapture or you're just
down a piece see capture son d5 and here
comes Knight to g5 and here we have a
beautiful position where the queen is
now actually able to escape them but
first you have to deal with this small
threat a threat of checkmate there
really isn't a great way to deal with
this you kind of have to play g6 f5 is
no better g6 was played in the game and
in case this is the first time you were
actually seeing this game I feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
absolute best move for white it's really
really a nice maneuver I'll give it a
couple of seconds as usual for those of
you who were able to find the
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those who just want to
enjoy the show here David played Knight
captures on h7 I wonderful move because
the knight is immune to capture if King
captures then rope to h3 check you
simply and give a little check and now
you're able to capture the Queen on e4
black loses the Queen end the game so we
have to play something here of course
you cannot capture the night
Bishop to f5 was played attacking the
Queen here so you have to react to this
first Knight to f6 check you have to
move the King but you can't really move
the King okay not h7 but you can't go
King to h8 because again you get ripped
to h3 check captures and again you lose
the Queen so you can I have to go King
to g7 this was played in the game and
now how do you continue the attack well
simply try and give up more material
Bishop h6 check and here you have three
options again King to h8 King captures
Bishop and King captors night so what do
you play here if you go King - h8 then
Bishop captures on f8 a wonderful move
you simply give up the Queen I mean well
what's you know who needs a queen Bishop
captures and rook 2 H 3 this will be
checkmated the knight guards these
squares bishop guards g7 so there's no
way for the king and there's no way to
block check this would be checkmate on
the other hand of course if you capture
the bishop again
rook to h3 a deadly move as always
Bishop captures again you lose the Queen
we will already seen this
so after Bishop to h6 black tried King
captures on f6
and here this is this is a spectacular
position again feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the winning
idea for white as usual give it a couple
of seconds for those of you who were
able to find it
congratulations here Paul Morphy Adolph
Anderson McHale tau Rashid mesh Medina
are all applauding you for your great
showing if if you found the correct move
if you found Queen d2 then it's not all
that impressive yes you are threatening
checkmate but black can actually block
and block the rooks presence and the
e-file and now Queen g5 check King e6
and the king can escape but if you found
the strongest idea here that is g4 which
was played in the game then all of this
stands and this is the way chess chess
was meant to be played I mean this is
just this is just spectacular so what's
the idea behind g4 of course if you
capture the Queen you get this beautiful
rook to have three Czech bishop goes
back to a5 blocking check and now comes
g5 and this is checkmate
Bishop garz g7 the rook is controlling
the entire efile and of course the pawn
gives a check a wonderful idea on the
other hand if you don't capture the
Queen and you don't do anything g5 will
be checkmate you know all the same on
the other hand if you try blocking the
e-file with the bishop so you can try
and escape using e-cigs and d7 our white
will simply prevent this with rook
captures D captures and now Queen
captures again g5 is the threat of
checkmate and there's really no good way
to stop it you can push g5 yourself to
prevent white from pushing g5
but then again rook f3 check better past
the block and now Queen e5 check the
bishop is now pinned King goes to g6 and
Queen to g7 will be again checkmate so
here after g4 Galoob of tried Bishop to
f4 you have to try something giving
further protection on the F file and
also preparing to capture this bishop
with Bishop captures on h6 and here
there is a one move only one good move
for white and
the move now it found in this game but
again I feel free to pause the video
here and try to find yet another move
because this this game is simply full of
beautiful puzzles to solve so try to try
to find the best idea here for those of
you who were able to do it once again
congratulations everyone is applauding
you as this is just one one spectacular
game Queen to c7 and this is this is
simply first the light square bishop
wasn't allowed to capture the Queen now
the dark square bishop isn't allowed to
capture a queen if you capture the Queen
now then it's all the same g5 comes and
this will be checkmate on the other hand
after this Queen to c7 if you tried
something like rook F to e8 to prevent
because here the Queen to c7 is a
powerful move because Queen to e8 this
is the threat the Queen e7 will be the
threat of checkmate so if you try
blocking this so the Queen now cannot
come to e7
then comes g5 with Czech Bishop captures
and g5 and now Queen to d6 with Czech
rook sorry about that
rook has to block row captures pawn
captures and now Queen to e5 check King
to f7 rook captures on b7 with the check
Bishop to e7 and now Queen g7 check King
moves and Queen captures on e7 a
beautiful forced variation you know by
white if such a move was played it's
it's a forced forced checkmate so here
Bishop captures and h6 seems to be the
only viable viable move as now the king
can hopefully escape the g7 but white it
doesn't allow it Queen to e5 with check
what can you do here King to g5 was
played and now comes h4 with check
simply bring the King deeper into your
own side of the board
King captures and now yet another
beautiful move rook to h3 check giving
up more material to bring the King
closer of course you cannot capture here
if you capture Queen to g3 will be
checkmate
so here King to g5 was played and here
we have Queen to e7 and it was in this
position unmoved 28 that severely Galoob
of
the game what if you resign well
whatever you do here you're getting
checkmated for example you can capture
the pawn and then you get Queen to h4
checkmate if you try after Queen to e7
if you're tracking to f4 then first you
get Queen to e3 which check King
captures and now you get Queen to g3
checkmate and lastly but not leastly
f6 nicely blocking check but again you
get Queen to e3 game captures and again
Queen Queen to g3 will be checkmate so
there we have it this is one of the
games that had everyone in the world you
know all worked up what an amazing game
was played and I definitely agree not
really sure about what the title of this
video will be I kind of feel like
anything I think of will not be
sufficient for such a such a grand game
so feel free to suggest a title for this
video as well as not sure if I'll I'll
be able to think of anything worthy of
such a game so a beautiful game from
round 6 of the 2018 course no memorial
by Russian Grandmaster David a Peruvian
so I do hope you enjoyed it I would like
to thank Santos Akhilesh Anika VR giver
Dani McCullough Steve C Royce and
Thurston grassman for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it and now I didn't mention
we're gonna discuss what the quest
question mark in the left top corner is
it's an idea I had while washing dishes
none other for some reason I thought it
would be it would be a nice idea if I
gave you a quest not perhaps not every
way video but maybe every other video or
something I'll just see if you enjoy the
idea and if you like it so I will give
you a quest and then if you are able to
fulfill the quest you just you know
printscreen that you were able to do it
and use the hashtag augur matter quest
it will be the first thing you see in
the description below just use that on
any social media and I think it will be
also a nice way to to create an even
larger community and expand it to other
medias for example for this quest I
decided
you have to beat an opponent on any
platform for playing chess regardless of
which one you use but you have to finish
the game with all of your 8 points so
you are not allowed to exchange any
points so you can use any time control
and you have to beat someone pretty much
on your own level let's say a hundred
rating points plus - so if you are 2,000
you can beat someone that's like 1900's
or 2100 so that's basically it for this
challenge just you know try to try to
accomplish it a bit an opponent without
wasting any of the pawns and if you were
if you will be able to complete this
quest then printscreen it and publish it
on any social media using hashtag other
matter quest and then I'll see how this
thing will evolve if it if you if you
guys will enjoy it I'll try to think of
some more creative quests for other
videos and ER you will also be able to
suggest quests you know there could be a
lot of funky quests like you know try to
finish the game with three Queens on the
board or try to finish the game with I
don't know any anything could go like
without touching your D and E pawn or
you know a lot of interesting quests
could happen so there you have it I will
put a short description of this a gamete
request idea in the description below it
will be the first thing you'll see so if
you feel like it you know give it a try
maybe maybe in the future we'll have
like some way of actually measuring who
is completing the most quests and you
know perhaps you'll be able to level up
and something I don't know it's just an
idea I thought of while doing the dishes
so there you have it so for those of you
who were with me until the end of the
video I do hope you enjoyed that as well
so as usual you can check - on my
previous videos here thank y'all for
watching and you know hope hope to see
you soon with another interesting video
although a game like this happens not
too often you know once in a couple of
maybe maybe twice a year I'd say or
maybe once a year I don't know about the
definite
exciting times and hopefully more games
like this will happen in the future so
thank you all and I'll see you soon